i'm going to do the calendar trick with
you today uh which is a bit of an old
mathematician's trick if you give me a
date i can tell you which day of the
week it is i'm hoping to teach you how
it's done as well okay well i've got the
book of calendars goes back to 1800 goes
up to 2100. let's do june 18. oh right
okay so 1976.
all right
june 18 1976. so i'm going to think
about this think about the year first so
1976
uh-huh and june you said
and what was the date are you saying 18
is it a friday
i don't know let's find out this is this
is tension now june 19.
yes it is oh wow i'm so glad that worked
i tried to look confident but i'm really
glad that worked
yes you know you could test me again to
prove that i really know what i'm doing
january 1
1901 going down so the year 1901
and you're saying uh january
one uh i is it a tuesday
tuesday
wow
wow
so i think it's time that i taught you
how to do this so it's a calculation
i haven't memorized every calendar in
that book by the way it's nice to tell
people you have but i haven't there's
more than one way of doing this but i'm
going to show you something called the
doomsday
method which was devised by our friend
john conway in the 1970s and to do this
you need to memorize some special dates
the fourth the fourth by which i mean
fourth of april sixth of the sixth so
six of june eighth of the eighth eighth
of august 10th of the 10th 10th of
october and 12th of the 12th 12th of
december and what is quite cool is all
these dates are on the same day of the
week and week it's nice fact isn't it i
didn't know that i know it's a lovely
little fact keep that in your pocket
yeah so that special day of the week we
call that the doomsday because that's
going to be special for what we're going
to do next in fact there's more i can
show you some other special dates the
9th of the 5th
the 5th of the 9th
the 7th of the 11th the 11th of the 7th
also share the same day of the week as
all those doomsday will change every
year but i know that these dates are all
sharing the same day of the week so for
example if i know that the fourth of
april is a monday then i know that all
of these dates are going to be a monday
for that year oh by the way nice way to
remember some of these i mean the these
even ones are quite nice to remember
these ones i work nine to five at the
7-eleven that's sort of a way to
remember it i haven't talked about
january february and march slightly
trickier because of the leap year
problem for january the special date is
the third or it's a fourth on a leap
year so to remember that it's it's the
third of january for three years and
then it's a fourth on the fourth year
for february it's the last day of
february which is 28th normally but 29th
on a leap year these dates will share
the same day of the week as all my other
special dates i've only left out march
and so for march
the special date for you to remember is
the 14th of march or as mathematicians
like to call it pi day pi day
is doomsday so if you know
the day of the week if you happen to
know the day of the week for pi day you
will know all these special dates for
the rest of the year
now the date you want to know is not one
of these special dates where you just
adjust so all i have to do is find the
nearest special date and then i add or
subtract a few days one thing to
remember when you're doing that is if
you add seven days you end up back to
where you started so if it was a monday
and i add seven days i get back to a
monday again if i had to add 15 days
then i might add 14 which takes me back
to monday again and then i'll add one
more what shall we do
a date in the future yeah um what do you
want 20th of christmas christmas lovely
christmas let's talk about christmas in
2021 now i happen to know that pi day in
2021 was a sunday so i know it's a
sunday i now find the closest date
where's that where it's going to be the
12th of the 12th
so i know the 12th of the 12th was a
sunday as well but i need to add on 13
days i add seven takes me back to sunday
and i add six more days takes me to
saturday so i now know that christmas in
2021 is a saturday so that's kind of
nice as a kind of a life hack if you
happen to know what pi day is for you
that year you can work out all the days
of the week for the rest of the year and
that's kind of a nice little fact to
have in your pocket of course if you
really want to be impressive about this
then you want to be able to do this for
any year that you're given but that
involves working out what pi day is or
doomsday is for that year so let me show
you how to do that
okay if you want to work out doomsday
for some year in the future let's do
that then one thing you need to remember
is uh doomsday for the year 2000 and i
will just tell you this as a fact in the
year 2000 doomsday you can call it pi
day or whatever you want was a tuesday
in 2001
our special day was a wednesday in 2002
our special day was a thursday in 2003
it was a friday in 2004
a special day it was a sunday and then
if i keep going like 2005 is a monday
and so on hopefully you can see what's
going on so every year goes forwards one
day and a leap year it goes forwards an
extra day so if i want to work out
doomsday for a year in the future then
what i do i know 2000 was a tuesday i
then just add on the year because i'm
adding as many days as the year and then
i add on how many leap years we've got
as well and that's the calculation i'll
be doing in my head so if i do
an example 20 20. okay so if i do 2020
so i know 2000 started on a tuesday you
actually add on the years to the 20
years
and then i have to add on how many leap
years which means i take the year and
divide by four if i divide by four here
i'm going to get a five don't care about
fractions you can throw those away but
in this case there weren't any fractions
so i'm going to start with tuesday add
25 days
so what's that going to be i don't care
about sevens so i can i don't care about
21 i can just disappear and i would have
four left over
so it's going to be tuesday plus four
more days so i know doomsday in 2020 is
a saturday if i then want to work out a
date in 2020
i then just do the doomsday method and
find a special date and adjust from
there
and that's all there is to well i say
that's all there is to it that's the
calculation i'm doing in my head you can
do this calculation you get better at it
with practice
and i can actually show you some sort of
tips and tricks so that you can get
really good at this
okay tips and tricks one is to convert
the days of the week into numbers
because then it just turns the
calculation into a sum so i'm not
thinking oh tuesday plus 25 days it just
becomes a regular sum so this is a
conversion for days of the week sunday
think of that as non-day monday is one
day tuesday to stay and wednesday
thursday that's a three thursday fourth
day friday five day they almost all work
i know it's lovely isn't it it's lovely
how they work so nicely saturday
six a day and that's going to be s6 so
now when i'm doing this calculation it
is just a sum it just works out nicely
and then i convert it back to the day
the last thing i do is convert it back
to a day of the week and then you give
that answer
now if you wanted to really show off
you could do a century as well i'll
really quickly show you how to do a
century
i've shown you how to do the 21st
century so the the 2000s because i said
that the doomsday in 2000 was a tuesday
what about if you wanted to do someone's
birth date and they're born in the 1900s
i'll show you how to do that as well
it's really simple actually doomsday in
2000 was a tuesday 1900 it was a
wednesday this is just something you
remember if you really want to show off
you could do the 1800s doomsday was a
friday and if you want to go back to the
1700s doomsday was a sunday so if you
want to do one of those centuries do the
same calculation but you start from
those positions
and if you want to do the future that
pattern repeats
so i've got a pattern here sunday friday
wednesday tuesday and it keeps going so
the 2100s that starts with a sunday and
then it would be a friday wednesday
tuesday and so on so you can do any
century finally during the year because
that's quite hard i we did an example
there which was 2020 and that was
relatively easy because 2020 the 20 was
quite a small number
now if it's a bigger number it gets
quite hard so imagine if i am doing a
date like 90 we started with 1976 and
i'll go okay i've got 1976 and then i've
got to work out the leap years of 97.
then i've got add them together and take
away the sevens okay so i'm going to
show you some shortcuts for the year as
well do you know there's only 28
calendars and then the pattern repeats
every 28 years here are some key years
to remember zero is a zero but 28 is a
zero as well because the pattern starts
again
56 is a zero because the pattern starts
again and 84 is a zero because the
pattern starts again so if you gave me a
date say
1988 what i wouldn't do is think oh now
i have to start at 1900 add 88 years and
add the leap years and uh that's going
to be quite hard what i'm going to do
instead is think okay 1900 starts with a
wednesday
i know 84 is a zero year so then i just
start from 84 and add on four more years
so then i add on four add one leap year
and i know that that's going to be a
five so i had them five days after
wednesday uh so that's all i would have
to do and also which is what which is
and this is why we need those numbers as
well wednesday is a three
plus five is an eight
sevens disappear so it's a one it
becomes monday that's why those numbers
suddenly become useful because you you
stopped there didn't you you went okay
wednesday plus a five is
and that's why those numbers suddenly
become useful conway broke it up a
little bit more he broke it up like this
way zero he started with 12 24 36 48 60
72 84 96 if you notice there are
multiples of 12 and he remembered that
zero is a zero 12 is a one
24 is a 2 36 is a 3.
48 is a 4. 60 is a 5. 72 is a 6. 84 is a
7 and 96 is an 8. so he memorized that
and that kind of breaks up the century a
bit more so when i did the calculation
for brady at the beginning it was what
was it 18th of june 1976 what i didn't
do is go oh 1976. oh that's a hard
calculation i knew 72 was a six and i
started there that's a six plus four
years
is now a 10 plus a leap year is an 11
plus the century
is a three so now i've got 14. oh 14
disappears
oh i was really pleased suddenly
disappears suddenly it becomes a zero
again and then we went and did the
doomsday method on the 18th of june so
the closest special date is 6th of june
and then i go oh well i know the 6th of
june is a 0 because that's my doomsday
calculation and i added on 12 more days
so i got a 12 i knew i could ignore the
sevens i went oh the answer is five and
the last step is going oh if the
answer's five i convert that into a
friday and i can say friday
it's my birthday was it your birthday
you see i could have prepped this but
then this was live i actually did it
nice yeah phew he's a bit number wang
well this is appropriate and a lovely
coincidence i'm building a perpetual
calendar it's the latest box of genius
to arrive from kiwico everything i need
is already in the box and comes with
instructions that are not only clear
but they're filled with these little
extra bits of knowledge
the subscription crates are just a great
way to dive into science and technology
engineering the arts and mathematics
nothing gives you a better feel for how
things work how the world works than
doing the building yourself
i've been sending monthly crates to my
nephew down at australia as you've
probably seen before but let's be honest
these are great for people of all ages
you can get 50 off your first box by
using our url kiwico.com
number file
it's there on screen and in the
description if you want to go and have a
click
do it for yourself or do it for the
young learners in your life
don't waste another day
see what i did there with the wasting a
day thing
if someone says are you coming to my
birthday when is it like 18th of june
and then you go uh am i free
yes it's a wednesday i am free on that
day genuinely i think there is something
you could do with this but also you can
show off at nerdy parties
do you ever use this though wouldn't you
just check your calendar on your phone
yeah that's not the fun though it's all
part of the fun doing the calculation
and showing off it's all part of the
phone of course you could check on your
phone